sin or religion rather is as I said just
giving God what he deserves that's what
religion most religion is the thing that
presupposes that God is a thing that you
can give what certainly also presupposes
that God exists yeah but so no so that's
what I'm saying it's like you can't say
that you can't Define religion as giving
God what what he will but you that's
that's the whole thing you're kind of
sneaking the definition in without
substanti you know yes religions uh
Orient themselves toward God that's true
so if you're
that orients itself towards a God or
tries to uh theorize about God or Gods
yeah it just yeah it acknowledges that
God exists yeah well no it belief it's a
belief that God does exist you see what
I mean there it's a true opin I know I
know that you see what I mean there
because I know you're a smart guy so I
know that like your rhetorical
strategies are are can be on point but
the thing is if you're saying why do you
think they're on point I think it's on
point because a lot of people who are
watching this who don't really who might
not like me or might not be they like or
maybe maybe they do but a lot of them
who might not be too versed on like
rhetorical strategies can see because
they believe it's like yeah it's just
acknowledging that God Rel persuasive in
this case perhaps because it's well
reasoned no it's not at all I think it's
because of the way that you say things
if you would let me finish explaining
why I think it's on point I think
because when you just said right there
you said uh it's uh acknowledging that
God exists right yeah that's because
it's a common sense statement to you and
to your audience if you say religion is
acknowledging that God exists that of
course they're going to say yeah because
I believe God exists and if you're
religious you acknowledge that God
exists but you kind of leaped past which
is why it's not reasonable or sound you
leap past the part where wait do we
really know that a God exists and if we
do how do we demonstrate well here's how
we demonstrate uh things are in motion
right we're in motion you and I are in
motion the Earth is in motion the stars
are in motion the galaxies are in motion
uh uh things in motion do not put
themselves into motion so I like for
instance if I had a ball here I could
take this ball and I could throw it
at another ball on that desk over there
and then that ball this ball that was
moving that I threw would hit the other
ball and that ball would fall down on
the ground it would roll and that ball
would maybe roll over I don't know
another little tiny ball on the ground
and it would keep you would see things
continue to move as a consequence of
those actions so we can go back and you
say well Michael how did you start
moving and I'll tell you I started
moving because my mother and father
loved each other one night and they
created me and how did that and you can
go back through all of these uh actions
that caused movement but ultimately
you're going to have to come to an
unmoved mover who is God or no you could
actually so it could be an unmoved mover
it could be that there's a finite amount
it reduces by finite amounts the amount
of movement so in that ball analogy when
you throw the ball and it hits another
ball it would be slowly slowing down
because of the force of friction so it
could be something that was moving or
maybe has the potential to be moved that
just hasn't been actualized yet it
doesn't need to be an unmovable mover
and if it is I'm not saying at I'm
saying the unmoved Mover is at the
beginning yeah I'm saying yeah it
doesn't yeah I'm saying the beginning
doesn't need to be an unmoved mover and
if it is bring and if we're if it is and
we're bringing it back to a a god
perspective then if God is the same
today tomorrow always and it's the
unmoved Mover then what does prayer do
think about it if God is changing their
mind about something not changing their
mind but say I call to say I pray to God
say I pray to God about something right
I want him to fulfill something for me I
want him to uh make my water into wine
right here let's say that I pray to God
for that he'd have to do something that
he wasn't doing already in order to make
that happen you have to answer my prayer
correct but God God if God were to exist
God would be the creator of All Things
by definition yeah so God would create
not only space but
time right so God would necessarily be
outside of space and outside of time oh
he wouldn't necessarily he could again
we're talking the maker of all things
then he made time no well I mean if he's
the maker of all things he could make
time but he could also make himself
subject to time because again this the
power of a God we're talking about we're
operating on the framework that as we
understand time the thing that has to
create time has to be outside of it but
like I was saying God doesn't enter into
time in the Incarnation you've arrived
at an important distinction between
before before we before we get to the
distinction I want to press down on the
fact that if God has created this water
right here this water currently is not
wine doesn't matter at which point he
decides to make it wine he has to decide
to make it wine that is in a sense in in
in a sense the unmoved Mover moving cuz
you have to be in a state of mind to
okay I made this this is water I now
want this to be wine that is you making
a decision you are changing your mind
about something that's the case then God
has to be a moved mover because you
cannot say that oh well you know what
he's just an unmoved mover but I'm going
to pray to him and he's going to do
something for me that he hasn't already
done because he has to change something
about himself in order to do that thing
well our lives unfold in history and the
the way to understand God's relationship
to history is through a concept of
Providence uh Christianity is especially
an historical understanding of God
because God takes on human flesh in the
Incarnation then lives for 33 years and
then is crucified and then on the third
day rises again from the dead and then
he's on Earth for 40 days and then he
ascends up into heaven and sends the
Holy Spirit to his church which is the
visible expression of God's kingdom here
on Earth so I'm with you in God's role
in history but the the error you've made
is that you uh have forced God to be
subject to time before God made time no
I'm saying but again this is assuming
that he did any of those things but I'm
saying how do you know that he couldn't
have made himself subject to that time
how do we know that it's without how do
we know that it's outside of the
possibility of a God to both create time
and create himself in the time how do we
know that one has how do we know that
one has to proceede another for
operating on the framework of God
because the creator has to proceed the
created yeah SP SpaceTime created it's
part of the physical creation well does
it have to again we're talking about God
here if I create something I have to
pred that thing if God creates something
we don't know what God can do we're here
talking about abortion and life and
everything in our aspect apparently
there are angels and everything that are
subject to a completely different realm
when it comes to life and how they
perceive it subject to God's sovereignty
no I no I'm saying yeah I mean of course
but I'm saying that um we
for all we know life could be created on
in a billion different ways it doesn't
even just have to be the way we came
about if we have angels we have other
things up in a different realm in heaven
that's life don't get into the aliens no
no I'm saying that's life but it's it's
subject to a completely different
subsector rule so we're saying the way
we internalize it is well obviously
something has to proceed this other
thing has to proceed this other thing
has to proceed this other thing that not
only is does not have to be the case
with a god even if that is the case all
it could imply is that there could be
various things it could gradually
decrease it doesn't have to be a a
singularity it could be a a string of
things that are kind of gradually going
about it doesn't even have to it could
be an infinite develop in history it
could be an infinite regress for all we
care we don't know it can't be that how
why can't it not because there has to be
an unmoved mover or I'll give you let
let's say if this if this if that's if
it's if we're looking at change right if
we're talking about an unmoved mover or
whatever how is it that change is just
conceptualized as just something
preceding after another right we could
change could be a change in color a
change in property of something right we
could say that something created
something or whatever and it wasn't even
necessarily just a progression of it it
just kind of shifted in color or it
gradually decreases or anything any of
the above possibilities CU we're talking
about a God here for you to assume that
because one thing must cause another
must cause another must cause another
and we can't have ever I'm just saying
it yeah they right
they the happened now just by definition
has followed the thing that immediately
preceded it yeah right in our world yes
so I'm saying if we're working within
the scope of a God we have no idea what
laws or or or we do because we're made
in the image and likeness of God that's
how we can well but so so I'm so you
can't say that well I know this property
about God and God definitely has this
property because I'm made in the image
of God and this is how it works
presupposing that that God even exists
in how do you know anything how do I
know anything um I usually analyze like
uh I I think the basis for knowing
things is subject to uh evidence so
basically when I say I know that I'm
like here right it's not like I pulled
out a bunch of dictionaries and I'm like
what is the definition of here it's we
it's a known fact about the world that
people exist and I'm exper conscious huh
because we can see that we can observe
how do you know what you're seeing is
real and not just a hallucination that's
a big question I don't think you truly
can know that I think I can know whether
but you're very confident in your
opinions I think but you just said
you're not confident that I'm also
confident in the things that I don't
know I think it's confidence being able
to say when you don't know a thing I
think that but what you've just said is
you don't know for certain that you know
anything at all yeah I don't think you
can know anything for certain I'm I'm
reasonably certain that you cannot know
anything everything for certain well of
course not but but but I'm not asking if
you can know everything or you can know
anything anything for certain you can
know it to a degree of certainty I think
you can get infinitely close to like
that 100 you can get 99.99 depending how
can you get that close how can you get
that CL
evidence how do you know that you can
rely on the evidence that you're seeing
well I think that knowing that I can
rely on the evidence that I'm seeing I
can always like see evidence that leads
me astray but it's a process of like
mental reasoning that you can see
various things that lead up or that uh
give good warrant to beling a certain
proposition that doesn't by default mean
that that proposition is true if you're
going to go for the brain in a vet it
could all be a simulation we genuinely
don't have an answer to that I'm not
saying I'm not even asking that I'm
asking well that's kind of what you're
asking it isn't how do you know that you
can rely on your faculty of reason to
communicate to you the truth because I
think that how how do you know that your
your reason is Dependable if I think my
reasons Dependable or I know my reasons
Dependable because of things like
evidence it's so when I look at when I'm
when I'm analyzing yeah so I'm saying
when you're building your reason right
why would you have reason to believe
something well I know the the things
that I have to operate within me right
now I know that I have articles that I
can read about abortion I know I can I
have studies and everything I can say
further back than that yeah I'm saying I
can say that like oh well I don't know
this for certain again that can track
back to literally everything maybe I'm
not asking the question properly I'm I'm
not asking how you have an opinion about
abortion I'm asking how
you trust that any opinion you reach
that any perception you have about
anything is reliable and has some
accordance with reality so that's the
again that's the brain in of that
question because what what you're saying
is how do you even so if I say um I
think that that cup has or this cup has
water in it and you're saying well how
do you know that and I'm like well we
know that water exists we have the
molecular makeup whatever and you're
like well how do you know can rely on
molecular makeup I'm like well there's a
science there's a field of scientists
that have broken down the the
composition of water and you're like how
no but I'm saying and you're saying well
how do you know that you can even rely
on that and it's like well truthfully I
don't think you can know anything for
100% but you can you can work within the
framework that you're operating AUM
right it's an axum that you're just
beginning with so what you're beginning
with is precisely where I begin which is
that you are made in the image and
likeness of God in the defin about you
is your reason so you're saying that the
only think it means only way so wait
okay wait so and it's funny because this
argument doesn't even support theism
because you could be created in the
image and a likeness of a God but what's
to say that that God is the reason for
why you have reason what do you think
the phrase being made in the image and
likeness of God
means literally whatever people who
believe in a god want it to mean it
Christians even disagree about this in
the same way it could be oh well we're
just we are just like God we can be
co-eternal with God if we take the right
steps or it could be there's Christian
Science no it's not Christian Scientists
it's a oo I forgot what the religious
Domin denomination of Christianity is
but they do actually believe that they
have like a is it Mormons they have a
father mother God and they believe that
each of them can can become like God but
they can never Excel to the level of God
that's just their personal belief what
what what would it mean to what would it
mean it's funny well I don't the thing
is I don't know what that you don't know
the answer so the answer is I don't
believe it so okay but you can you you
can know things about things that you
don't so whatever properties whatever
properties you what I think that being
being made in the image of likeness of
God is is whatever properties you
attribute to that God you guys share
similar prop it's not a trick question
actually that that no that's what I'm
that's what my answer is it's whatever
there's more specific answer which is
our intellect and our will our reason
that that is what that is the answer
that you believe is the case because you
could very well believe no you could
very well believe in your God and people
who believe in a different God than you
could believe could believe that being
made in the image of them is a
completely subset different subset of
categories and attributes that we
attribute to ourselves again you would
need to demonstrate that your is the one
and only correct one first before you
base your Axiom off of all that CU
you're just working off a big assumption
no matter how deeply you believe it at
the end of the day it is one big
assumption and at least I can show you
progress in steps to where I can get you
can't you just said that you have to
assume that your reason is reliable you
have to take that merely as an
assumption as a premise to start with
you can you can test that if I can if I
come up with various conclusions say if
we wanted to know something say if we
wanted to know what water is right and
if we came up with a criteria by which
we measure that and the chemical
composition and everything right and we
see we studi the the water cycle we
study everything that has to do with
water and we come up with a very we come
up with predictions on okay well given
these circumstances water should act
like this if we got all our properties
down and we reasoned through this and we
knew this correctly we're able to know
something correctly then given that
water should act like this in this given
circumstances we have yet to be wrong
about that I don't know if water can
just go from freezing to just vanish in
an instant it could but we have no
demonstration of that all we have is a
pattern of research and and
understanding to this point that shows
that we're able to make predictions and
see this is actually how this is working
so with that in mind we can say okay
this is fairly reasonable we can rely on
this if we were just looking at it as
like well water's clear which means it
must be have some property of becoming
invisible well it we can say oh yeah
well I I think that that's the case but
if it continuously gets proven wrong and
it never happens then that's not a
reason
but you're you're if you're going to ask
me how do we know that patterns are
reasonable well or or how do you know I
mean to use the example that you like
coming back to how do you know that
you're not just uh you know living in a
video game or something again that would
be an assumption it's just a
premise I don't know if I would I don't
know if like I think that I wouldn't
call it an assumption or I wouldn't call
it a premise or anything because I don't
genuinely think that you can know that
but you live though you're not I don't
think that you I don't think you live as
though things are significant I don't
think that even if your brain was in a
vet I don't think that means that the
things we're experiencing aren't
significant that's one of the things
that gets back to God I think if we
living even without a God I don't think
that that means that everything isn't
significant but you live as though your
faculties of Reason are are dependable
and that you're not being perpetually
deceived well yeah and you talk about
perpetually deceived how do you
determine you're not being perpetually
deceived I think you're lying if you
don't realize that it's analyzing the
things that are at your disposal and
making predictions and analyze you just
yeah you you have to take it you have to
if you're going to if you're going to
say because we 100% don't know for
certain that everything around us is a
figment of our imagination therefore
we're operating on faith and that faith
is the same Faith as this God who
apparently has told you everything you
need to do and could never be wrong
despite the fact that everyone else
believes in different gods that's not
quite what I'm saying it's close you're
trying to draw that not what I'm saying
is that what what I'm saying is that
there are many different modes of
inquiry a philosophical deliberation
scientific inquiry and all number of
manner of inquiry uh but they all have
to begin with intuitive reason and with
the Assumption of premises in the same
way that mathematics has to begin with a
with a set of assumptions a plus b
equals B plus a you can't prove that but
those are the the those are some of the
you can prove that once you test it if
you if I say if I say I say about that
if I say 2 + 2 equal 4 right again the
the we can say that the the number
system that we developed for it is like
a figment of language but the principle
if you have two objects and you add two
more objects and you count but I'm
saying even more you to begin with 3 +
2al 2+ 3 for yeah so if we did that then
we could we could run experiments or
test to make sure this formula applies
in every scenario we shouldn't get 3 + 2
equal 1 + 7 we shouldn't get that at any
given point if our things are working
correctly let me see if if we continue
to get these same answers and we
continue to not be proven wrong in these
same things you can know with a higher
degree of certainty whether or not
you're correct about that if you know
all you could never know for sure that
everything around you is figment but
even if everything is around you is a
figment you still know things within
that figment and it's not necessarily
like the same leap leap of you just
don't know but you could be deceived at
any you wouldn't necessarily rely on say
continuity that the world you're living
in today is the same world that was that
existed but my thing is that you can't
know that either you say you can right
I'm just I'm just I'm just beginning
with certain and then using my reason
based on those premises yeah and if
we're going to if we're going to begin
with certain premises and everything
what would be more of being deceived Us
in reality all being brains and Vats but
not only do I I'm comfortable with
saying I don't know that for certain but
here's these things I can work with
whereas you say well no we're not a
brain in a vet I know this story and
this story is the one true story
everyone else's stories are wrong while
the told yeah greatest story you ever
told so it's like which one it would be
more of a level of Deceit you could say
that the one that's true would would be
the one that's true would be true no no
the one that's the one that's real and
true would be the Real and True one and
the one that's a deceit would be the
deceit